[Musique]
c'est à l'armée flore centre technique
d'expérimentation végétale à la réunion
que se sont tenues les deuxièmes
rencontres agro fertile junior 700
apprenant futurs professionnels du monde
agricole ont pu rencontrer et échanger
avec différents intervenants sur les
nouvelles techniques culturales
où en sont les travaux de recherches et
travaux d'expérimentation que ce soit à
sélection variétale que ce soit la
conduite plus écologique être vraiment
dans l'air du temps aujourd'hui on voit
bien les molécules sont sortis on a des
ravageurs qui rentrent tous les ans de
nouveaux ravageurs donc on sent bien
qu'il faut être un peu plus en harmonie
avec avec la nature qu'il s'agit de
remettre en place d équilibre et on a
vraiment besoin d de la recherche et
d'expérimentation donc c'est les encens
l'ensemble des partenaires qui sont
présents aujourd'hui une cinquantaine
d'ateliers proposés pour comprendre les
nouveaux outils qui offre une réelle
alternative à l'utilisation des produits
phytopharmaceutiques
concernant les ravageurs donc on avait
pas mal de nouvelles méthodes comme
l'installation justement de plantes
auxiliaires dont qui va justement
attirer les ravageurs pour justement
nous permettre de gérer au mieux notre
culture
le département en charge de la
compétence agricole a rappelé la place
centrale qu'occupe la collectivité les
fonds européen pour le développement
d'une agriculture locale ambitieuse
tournée vers de nouveaux systèmes de
production plus respectueux de
l'environnement
notre présence je pense permet aussi
d'apporter quelques éclairages quelques
explications sur qu'est ce que le
département que fait département c'est
quoi une autorité de gestion
d'où viennent les fonds de l'europe on
parle de feader mais c'est pas toujours
évident pour des jeunes de coups de
connaître ce ce discours donc il faut
absolument qu'on puisse communiquer de
manière très simple mais leur donner
tous les éléments leur dire que ces
enveloppes sont très importantes pour
l'agriculture à la règle le succès de
ces rencontres agro fertile junior marc
bien l'implication de tous les acteurs
d'une même filière pour la valorisation
de l'agroécologie au sein de
l'agriculture réunionnaise
[Musique]